hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play afraid of monsters okay we
left off we killed a roomful of head
hands and there's a button
boink oh that's down there that's the
door with the missing lock okay good
enough and it's a lot of running around
for very little official progress I know
hello hello hello I'm not gonna get
jumped by things in the sky again ha
oh no no no F F all of you I see you up
well bop Boop bop Boop bop Boop bop beep
can those little things go downstairs
maybe probably ha whoopee I don't get
well Paul maybe they can my good old
favorite game find the exploit
hello home yar
hello friend Oh aren't you just so close
oh yeah
anybody else anybody or hello I've come
back come back I dare your ha ha ha ha
ah ha boom come on I'm almost free I'm
running out of ammo here bomb yeah one
down
mmm ah don't dodge in there bump there
we go okay one shotgun shell left man
that was a lot of them pills anything
else
ooh lots of stuff double pills yes I'm
up out of the red health again ah so
epic oh yeah so great yeah one shot
one desert iike bulletin for ah no screw
screw you
uh-uh can't see alright there we go new
level ah higher show there huh go away
go away ah damn it I'm down health again
[ __ ] you ah no do it let me hi oh I got
where you come from
oh I don't have the bullets take care of
all of you ah maybe maybe maybe maybe
maybe maybe maybe maybe nah
zoom what I don't care I'm dying I'm
being murder lized why would you do that
if they kill me they [ __ ] kill me
those the douchiest thing they could
have done there we go okay that's two of
them down hopefully I'll be able to one
shot him with this come here come here I
need a better shot up let's quick save
and a Boppy there we go okay now I'm
down to one shotgun shell yeah yeah
that's my favorite all right this looks
like there's something up there
well there's a ladder right there maybe
I can use that
oh maybe oh I don't know how could you
tell how did you tell that there was
something up there thank you for the
shotgun shells whatever it's all good so
long as you're gonna be nice to me I
guess I can be nice to you
all right where the heck am I going whoa
oh no not again
okay I'm not going that way
definitely not um I guess I'll go down
here oh whoa buddy
no not today yeah yeah ha
nope ah ha I'm so gonna get you and not
ya bye oh yeah super app yeah so great
yeah Oh dodge up dude I'll miss ah damn
it
have you have you there we go got ya ooh
yeah oh man that guy is one tough
son-of-a-bitch way too tough more tough
than he should be
I'm definitely checking all the corners
trying to find some items because I like
you this entire game I've just been
running low the entire time okay so that
doors locked so I got to go find some
way to open it some way around I don't
know okay all right I guess I got to go
this way with the floaty heads
black okay if I run they can't hit me
whoop rubadoux swoop what's this
Whoopi do Petey screaming ah no oh don't
hit me don't hit me bro I stood
completely still and you didn't hit me
for long oh no I'm just screw you just
screw you Grieg ah ah no oh my god they
want me dead
oh they want me so dead what what what
what up up up up okay oh no not up up is
bad in here please give me some some
anything oh I need something hello
weird it works like a lady exploded head
light please
there we go yes light ah ah wha wha what
was that
oh oh ah uh huh what is that what what's
killing me
ah let me yeah
ah it's just eyes they're just eyes I
don't see ah you you what the hell ah oh
it's the big head Oh let's begin I saw
fur before I just need a shoot something
yeah there we go ah
oh okay I get two shots off and then oh
no wait ah no missed huh oh god damn I
don't have so little health uh okay then
I do things huh yeah I see you uh I'm
out of ammo
Oh how am I gonna do this ah yes ah damn
it
II
ah I see you through damn it ah damn it
I'm never gonna kill it I don't have I
don't have enough [ __ ] hell ah okay -
and then wait for it to do its thing
then it's gonna be right there oh nice
ah oh boy oh [ __ ] he'll [ __ ] hell oh
oh I do have bullets when did I pick up
those that kill it
I get ah no I did not okay boom and then
double whammy and then switch to the oh
okay reload first ok let do thing then
ohm and then jump oh it's not supposed
to do that but let me do a double yeah
no no yeah ah [ __ ] hell I can get
this I can get this [ __ ]
ah ah what the hell suddenly he's
trolling me
okay fu okay save I got two shots in
where'd you go there you are come on
where are you where I got ya I'm gonna
get you where are you where are you
buddy
right there ah okay you're right there
yeah yeah get some what I see you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you god damn it I hate that I
can't see him ah damn it it's like it
was three shots with the desert eagle
that just oh I have Desert Eagle ammo
yes yeah huh oh damn it
whoops oh I think that got him yes
oh man I'm saving the desert eagle
animal then cuz it is like uber powerful
push that back this is box for oh I need
to push this box down there okay whoa
damn it or maybe up here Oh up here not
down there down there would have been a
bad idea
aha oh so bright ah I see you
gotcha gotcha I know seriously I miss
there we go okay
now officially out of ammo [ __ ] and hell
now all I got left is the Desert Eagle
unless is gonna give me some please
please
batteries not what I needed all right
man scraping by with the bare minimum
just hanging on by the skin of my teeth
my tooth is ah almost fell to my death
head hand was you in here I got a knife
and six points of Hale's I'm ready for
an attack I know okay
you were a pretty tough guy right boom
oh hell hell boom there we go aha ammo
Oh Desert Eagle ammo actually flashing
later okay I got my one-shot pistol I
would think that a shotgun would be more
I missed no way no no taking a mulligan
on that one dog yeah big bout of blood
there we go some health finally
okay hello nope hello nope
lots of N crawling with no real idea
whoa
oh you're guarding some shotgun shells
so line up to shot
Oh what maybe I didn't get a head shot
hang on
go boom there we go
that's more like it all right you got
health and shotgun shells thank you very
much
I'll bow to you boom dropped okay oh boy
hey let me see what's down here if
anything ah boom what no no no no no I
know you guys probably don't like me
saving and loading so much but I got to
or else I'm never gonna make it I'm
never gonna make it through this game
unless I do things absolutely perfectly
aha and head shot yes anything under the
stairs
no what ah I need to switch those okay
quick saved before I quit living okay I
need a wrecker oh come on oh you gotta
be kidding me
okay you don't have a head so it's kind
of hard to hit yeah there we go
nailed you right in the face whoa okay
it's that thing I can get out up here
but what was up step what the hell
Oh oh my goodness
ah I'm dying I'm dying I'm dying
what's up here Oh Oh No
i poisoned me Wow oh okay there's
nothing up there there's nothing worth
getting at all and I'm getting up [ __ ]
out
ah ha ha they're everywhere oh they're
everywhere they are literally everywhere
all health please give me health ah
lock jammed uh-huh lock jammed jam lock
power in here
No ah I didn't take it good poison
poison mo ha deine I'm dying I'm dying
oh the boys uh keys okay huh get out I
got keys to where I don't know
close the damn door oh okay okay all
right
all right that's all the time I got for
this episode oh I don't even know where
the [ __ ] I'm supposed to go oh I got
keys but no idea where anyway thank you
guys so much for watching we enjoying it
oh man and I will see you in the next
part
bye bye